SO GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
FIRST OF ALL, HOW DID THIS IDEA
COME TOGETHER?
>> I LOOK FOR ANY EXCUSE TO
LEAVE THE STUDIO.
AFTER 22 YEARS OF HOSTING A
SHOW, I WILL JUMP AT ANY
OPPORTUNITY.
I WILL SHOOT A WHOLE SHOW FROM
YOUR BASEMENT IN D.C.
I WILL GO ANYWHERE.
I JUST WANT OUT OF THAT STUDIO.
SO WHAT HAPPENED WAS SHORTLY
AFTER PRESIDENT OBAMA ANNOUNCED
IN DECEMBER THAT THERE WERE
TALKS ABOUT ESTABLISHING
RELATIONS WITH CUBA AFTER 53
YEARS, MY HEAD WRITER MIKE
SWEENEY SAID CASUALLY WE SHOULD
GO TO CUBA AND I JUMPED ALL OVER
IT.
WE MOBILIZED, WE SCRAMBLED AND
GOT IT TOGETHER AS QUICKLY AS WE
COULD.
>> WHEN YOU GOT THERE, WHAT WAS
IT LIKE?
I KNOW YOU DIDN'T GO THERE AS A
REPORTER INVESTIGATING HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES, BUT DID YOU HAVE
GOVERNMENT MINDERS AT ALL?
>> NO.
WE HAD NO MINDERS.
WE HAD NOBODY FOLLOWING US,
NOBODY TELLING US WHERE WE COULD
GO, WHERE WE COULDN'T GO, AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY WHAT MADE THE
EXPERIENCE REALLY TERRIFIC IS WE
SENT OUR CAMERA CREW A DAY AHEAD
OF US.
THEY CAME IN THROUGH CANADA.
WE CAME IN THROUGH MIAMI AND WE
JUST SAID WE'RE TOURISTS AND
THEN HOOKED UP WITH OUR CAMERA
CREW AND WE STARTED SHOOTING
IMMEDIATELY.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN SO WE SHOT FOR PRETTY
MUCH FOUR DAYS CONTINUOUSLY, AND
GOT A LOT OF GREAT STUFF.
>> THEY OBVIOUSLY DON'T HAVE THE
INTERNET, THEY DON'T HAVE
AMERICAN TV THERE.
DID ANYONE HAVE ANY IDEA WHO YOU
WERE?
>> WELL, CUBANS DON'T KNOW BUT
HERE'S THE THING.
CUBA IS FILLED WITH TOURISTS,
TOURISTS FROM CANADA.
I'M A GOD IN CANADA.
WELL, OKAY, THAT'S GOING TOO
FAR.
BUT THEY KNOW WHO I AM.
I GOT A LOT OF FANS IN CANADA
AND ALSO, MY SHOW IS SEEN
THROUGHOUT PARTS OF SOUTH
AMERICA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SOUTH
AMERICAN TOURISTS, THERE ARE
EUROPEAN TOURISTS.
I EVEN HAD PEOPLE IN FINLAND WHO
WATCH THE SHOW REGULARLY WHO
RECOGNIZED ME.
I WAS RECOGNIZED BY EUROPEAN
TOURISTS AND SOUTH AMERICAN
TOURISTS AND CANADIANS BUT
CUBANS, NO.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
>> ISN'T IT THE PRESIDENT OF
FINLAND THAT'S YOUR
DOPPELGANGER?
AM I CONFUSING --
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT.
I BEAR A STRIKING RESEMBLANCE TO
THE FORMER -- I BELIEVE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF FINLAND.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS SHE'S A
WOMAN.
THAT'S SORT OF BAD NEWS FOR BOTH
OF US.
BAD NEWS FOR HER, BAD NEWS FOR
ME.
>> SO YOU OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T GO
FULLY STAFFED.
HOW WERE YOU ABLE TO BRING THE
LATE NIGHT PRESENTATION TO YOUR
SHOW?
WHAT ARE VIEWERS WHO TUNE IN
TONIGHT, WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO
SEE?
>> WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IS A
SHOW WHERE WE DO A LOT OF
IMPROVISATION.
AND NOT JUST IN MY TALKING TO
PEOPLE AND MAKING UP COMEDY ON
THE SPOT IN SITUATIONS, BUT WE
LITERALLY IMPROVISE A TALK SHOW
SET.
WE FOUND A STREET THAT LOOKED
PRETTY GOOD.
I ASKED A CAFE CAN I BORROW A
TABLE AND CHAIR.
THEY SAID YES.
THERE WERE FOUR YOUNG WOMEN
PLAYING SALSA MUSIC IN A BAND,
IN A RESTAURANT ACROSS THE
STREET, I SAID WOULD YOU LADIES
BE MY TALK SHOW BAND.
THEY SAID SI WHICH MEANS YES.
THEN WE FOUND A GUY WHO WAS
WILLING TO BE CUBAN ANDY.
SO MY SIDEKICK.
SO WE SET IT UP VERY QUICKLY AND
THEN WE SHOT AN OPENING, AN
ENDING AND DIFFERENT
WRAP-AROUNDS.
THE REST OF THE SHOW IS ME OUT
AND ABOUT IN HAVANA.
>> DID YOU MAKE THEM LAUGH?
I KNOW IT'S ONLY 90 MILES AWAY
FROM MIAMI, BUT THERE CAN BE
SOMETHING OF A CULTURE SHOCK AS
I UNDERSTAND IT.
>> YEAH.
THEY REALLY DID.
I THINK WHEN I BEHAVE LIKE AN
IDIOT IT'S A UNIVERSAL LANGUAGE.
SO I DID NOT WANT THIS IN ANY
WAY TO BE SNARKY OR ME BEING
CUTTING ABOUT THEIR CULTURE.
I WANTED TO GO AND IN A LOT OF
MY REMOTE SEGMENTS, THE JOKE IS
ON ME.
I'M THE FISH OUT OF WATER.
THAT'S REALLY THE SPIRIT THAT I
WANTED TO BRING TO IT.
I WANTED IT TO HAVE KIND OF A
SWEETNESS TO IT.
SO I WENT AND YOU CAN SEE THEM
THROUGHOUT, EVERYWHERE I WENT,
WHEN I'M BEHAVING LIKE AN IDIOT
WITH THIS ORANGE PASTRY ON MY
HEAD, AND MY SKIN TONE, IT LOOKS
LIKE I'M SICKLY.
THEY JUST START LAUGHING.
I THINK TO ME, THAT'S THE
GREATEST KIND OF DIPLOMACY IS,
YOU KNOW, DON'T GO IN AS LIKE
THE SCARY IMPERIALIST.
SEND CONAN IN FIRST SO THEY CAN